Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. Today, we're gonna be taking a look
at cdk8s,
a component library, SDK, and extraction for working
and defining and templating Kubernetes resources.
Before we end, there's just a little bit
of housekeeping that I'd like to cover.
First, please remember to subscribe to the YouTube
channel and click that bell. That means you're
gonna get notifications for further episodes as we
explore the cloud native landscape together.
Also, we have an active Discord channel and
server. Please come and join us. If you
wanna communicate after this because you're not watching
live, you have questions, or you wanna suggest
new technologies to cover on a show, Discord
is the best place to do that.
And also, I'd love to thank my employer.
They allow me to spend a good portion
of my time working on these episodes, producing
content for us to continue learning. The cloud
native landscape is vast
and we all need all the help we
can get to make sure we understand that
and leverage it as much as possible. If
you wanna check out Equinix Medal, there is
a code of Rawkode Live. This will get
you $50 in credit. That $50 will get
you around a hundred hours of compute on
a modest instance. Have fun with it. Let
me know how you get on.
Okay.
That's a bit done. Now cdk8s,
I do not know anything about cdk8s. I
haven't used it before, so of course, I'm
not gonna go on this journey alone. Today,
I am joined
by Elad Aben Israel, the maintainer and I
think founder of cdk8s.
Hello there, Elad. How are you?
Hey. Nice to be here. Thanks for having
me. No. No. It's all my pleasure. Thank
you for joining me today. We're really looking
forward to learn more about cdk8s and yourself.
So why don't we start there? Please give
us a little bit of an introduction into
who you are.
Okay.
So I I'm Elad.
I'm a
software engineer at Amazon
at AWS.
I've been there for about six years already.
And in the last three plus years, I've
been working on the on the CDK, the
cloud development kit.
It's a project that, originated from,
from from some work that we did, when
I worked with Amazon search
and basically kind of trying to just, you
know, solve real world problems of of being
able to define complex systems through software.
In a sense, it's kinda like the evolution
of infrastructure as code towards,
the software space.
And the first
three years almost of the project, we've focused
on
a product called AWS CDK, which is in
c which is,
which is a software
as a, sorry, infrastructure as a software,
tool for defining applications on AWS and, you
know, using AWS resources.
And at some point,
we realized that the approach is very applicable
to other domains,
and that's how CDK for Kubernetes,
was created. We we were, like, looking for
for
areas where the same approach can can apply,
and I can talk about it. And we'll
talk about it a little later.
But, basically, I've been doing CDK for the
past four years. It's been an
amazing pleasure. We have a really awesome team,
distributed across the world of maintainers of of
AWS CDK and CDK for Kubernetes and the
CDK ecosystem.
And, the most fulfilling part of my job
is that I've seen this community
kind of evolve from nothing. You know? Like,
we've just basically put this tool out there.
We didn't even spend too much energy or
or re or investment on, like, marketing or
trying to, like, push this too hard. It
was very, very organic.
And and I feel like it's
fulfilling because I feel like this organic growth
is is based on value. It's based on
actually solving problems for people, and, that's been
that's been incredible to see in the community
around the CDK,
AWS CDK, and CDK for Kubernetes, and there's
a CDK for Terraform now. And and so
this this CDK kind of ecosystem
is starting to evolve. It's very early. I
feel like we have
so much to do and so many things
to to still to, like
can still happen there, so it's very nice
and fun. But I've always been a developer
tools person. I've always the one that's
that's like writing these tools and shoving it
in peep my friends', you know, my friends'
face to, like, use. And finally, I'm doing
it. You know? I'm I'm I'm doing it
as a as a as my day job.
This that's been incredibly
fulfilling.
Yeah. And I think there's a couple of
things we can definitely touch on there for
sure. I I definitely consider myself a developer
tools person as well. I always find it
much more satisfying, right, in tools to automate
and help my developer colleagues rather than probably
work on the products themselves. It feels like,
you know, you've done exactly that with cdk
and cdk8s and all of these other kind
of variations of that as well. Yeah. There's
something really fulfilling about like helping people do
their job better and faster.
And Yeah. CDK
just in in general, I think is one
of those really awesome things. Like, I think
we've all been through the last, what, ten
years of infrastructure as code and the different
variations of it going from obscure DSL to
obscure DSL,
being constrained and confined by whatever the original
creators of those DSLs thought we needed to
do.
And,
you know, this really trivial and simple idea
of, well, why don't we just use our
favorite programming languages in order to be able
to build our own abstractions?
Why
did we not do this sooner? Like, I
just you know, in hindsight, it seems like
It seems yeah.
I think I think that, you know, I
can totally understand how that happened, and it's
happening in many fields as well. I think
the infrastructure space,
was originally
not a developer
led space. Right? Like, it was led by
people who were,
managing data centers. Right? Like, in infrastructure in
the past was basically a bunch of machines.
And so, you know, your data center
engineers would provision those machines and maintain them
and make sure they're, you know, up and
running, And then developers would come in and
just, like, shove their bits into those machines.
And so that separation was very, very clean,
and it was very easy to to manage.
And and so the tools around infrastructure as
code kind of came from
as an evolution of that. Right? In a
sense, their evolution
to to solve problems for for ops
engineers,
which are not or which which in some
cases are not developers. In many cases, they
are, but in some cases, they are not
developers. And the complexity that they needed to
manage is is is was very small at
the in the first place. Right? It's like,
okay. Let's define how my fleet looks like
or maybe the fleet in the database. And
and and I think what happened is that
and AWS is definitely, like, leading in this
space in a way, is, like, there is
a proliferation of managed services and managed resources,
that are available to develop to, you know,
to
app
creators.
And the there's a there's a shift between
from ops people
to developers to manage those resources because the
bound the line that kind of defines what
is an application and what is the infrastructure
is really becoming very blurry. Right? Like, when
you're when you're building a serverless application
and you're using Lambda functions and, you know,
day Dynamo tables, is the definition of your
Lambda function and the Dynamo table, is this
part of the application or part of the
infrastructure?
It's not that clear. Right? And so I
think that's what happened. Right? Like, can that
it's literally what happened to me. Right? Like,
when I needed to build
a big complex serverless application,
when I worked at Amazon Search, I was
like, wait. Wait. Wait. I'm not gonna rewrite
this huge
JSON file and deploy that to, like, multiple
regions and accounts and have, like, parameters tweak
things out for each one. Was like, I
have all those like you said. Right? Like,
I have those incredible tools and that I'm
using every day as a developer. I wanna
be able to just use them to define
my entire application, not just this little Lambda
handler. Right? Like, my so
that's how I feel this evolution,
is happening, and I'm I'm pretty excited that
that we're if they're making that available to
developers in their, like, native tools and familiar
spaces.
Yeah. Definitely. I think, you know, you must
be now getting to a position where you're
seeing, I guess, teams within Amazon and even
externally are using CDK to spin up their
own EKS clusters and provision or an s
three buckets and then using cdk8s to deploy
their applications to those clusters.
All within the same tooling, the developers are
really taking control of probably the entire stack
and
a very natural way to work with their
own tooling. I think one of the understated
things as well about cdk8s
and other tools like it is that because
you get to leverage, if you choose TypeScript,
you have this strongly typed definition of what
an EKS cluster should look like or what
your deployment should look like in Kubernetes. And
even just that
moving away from, you know, everyone's favorite programming
language, YAML, can give you a lot of
value add as well. So I'm very excited
to to be playing with that today. Yeah.
And and and I think that's an inter
interesting thing. Maybe we can talk about it
in the end if you're if you're if
we have some time. But this interoperability
between CDKs
opens up a lot of interesting possibilities. And
we've actually, like, added some capabilities, the AWS
CDK,
to support CDK for Kubernetes
definitions,
pretty natively. As and as you say, you
can, like, literally
define your cluster and you find your your
resources within the cluster
in the same code base. Right? Like, it's
the same application.
Yeah. Definitely.
I I think that probably leads me on
to my my first question. Oh, well, before
we do my first question, we have a
hello from Sunny. I'll pop that on the
screen. Hey, Sunny. Thanks for joining us.
Does writing the CDK for Kubernetes,
is it more difficult than, you know, a
domain like, you know, spinning up an ETS
cluster where the APIs are well defined? Like
Kubernetes, it's so extensible for custom resources. Was
that is that a challenge or does cdk8s
really can actually make working with those custom
resources easier for your Kubernetes operator or developer?
It was
it was an it was not a challenge,
but it was definitely an evolution of the
way we thought about the CDK because and
and in a sense, it's it's funny because
a similar thing happened in the AWS CDK,
but after we've released CDK for Kubernetes, I'll
I'll
roll back a little bit because the AWS
CDK has the has a fixed
low level surface area, which is CloudFormation. Basically,
synthesizes
CloudFormation templates.
And CloudFormation is the is a well defined
schema. Right? Like, it there's many,
many resources, but they're all very well defined,
and we know them in advance. And so
we we do in this AWS CDK,
we statically generate classes based on that schema
so that you can use,
the AWS CDK.
So you can use your programming language to
define those low level resources, and then we
have higher level resources. We'll talk about that
a little later. In Kubernetes,
like you said, the surface area is not
fixed. Right? Basically, there's the core Kubernetes API,
which is also a moving target.
Right? Like,
tons of changes and versioning and deprecations
and alphas and betas and blah blah blah.
And then there's an an basically, an open
ended surface area for custom resources.
And so when we approached CDK for Kubernetes,
we were like, okay. We need to take
a slightly different approach here because we can't
statically generate all those things because we don't
really know what the what users would would
need.
And so one of the key ingredients of
CDK for Kubernetes is what we call CDK's
import,
which is this capability to basically point
the CDK for Kubernetes a CLI
to a resource definition, whether it's a CRD
or the Kubernetes API at a specific version
Yep. And automatically generate those classes. We'll get
we'll we'll see that, obviously, when we when
we play. But but that was an interesting
difference. And the thing that happened after that
was that CloudFormation
had announced
that they're opening up the the resource model
for CloudFormation through CloudFormation registry,
which basically means that we actually have the
same,
the the same problem in c AWS CDK.
And we actually didn't we still didn't implement
CDK import,
but this is definitely the plan. Right? Like,
the idea is that these,
these, like, dynamic surface areas is something that's,
it's not too hard to support, but it's
definitely a difference from what we did in
the AWS CDK.
Awesome. Nice.
Well,
I think we should dive straight in there.
Let's let's start playing with it. Yeah. And
let's see what we can do here. So
let's pop over to our
screen share mode.
We're now floating bubbles. We have the cdk8
documentation.
And
I I always start these streams from a
complete newcomer perspective. There's no tools installed or
anything like that. So we're just gonna kinda
get ourselves through the documentation
and get started with a very simple example
and then we'll we'll have a bit of
a conversation and we'll see if we can
do something slightly more elaborate. I really would
largely kinda really wanna touch on the CRD
stuff, so we'll we'll hopefully get to that
as well. Okay. So I think one of
the superpowers of of cdk8s, sir, is that,
you know, we can see here we have
some prerequisites that tend
that allow me as a developer to work
with the tools and languages that are native
to me. So cdk8s
supports TypeScript, Python, and and Java. Is that
correct?
It's correct. But there's also,
technically, we also publish dot net support. It's
not it's still not documented because we we
wanna make sure that we get the best
experience.
And we even have
very, very preliminary Go support,
which is,
just,
just last week was, was when we finished
working on the
the the thing with with these language,
bindings
is that we actually generate them from the
TypeScript definitions. It's we use this technology that
we built for the AWS CDK called JSII,
which is pretty pretty cool.
And so when we add support for Go
AI, then suddenly we're able to deliver CDK
for Kubernetes and AWS CDK and CDK for
Terraform. And, basically all this all the all
the libraries that use JSII as their compiler.
In a sense, it's kinda like a a
subset of TypeScript that supports
binding to other languages.
And so we've actually we're we're wrapping up
support for developer preview for Go,
and that means that CDK for Kubernetes is
also gonna be available in Go soon. So
that's pretty exciting.
Yeah. I can imagine that's a fairly popular
choice among cloud native developers. Yes. Exactly. It's
probably the default language in 90% of the
cases.
I'm gonna hope I'm not the first person
to ask, but is is Rust on your
road map?
It's definitely on our radar,
especially given
that
some of the Rust maintainers are now, working
for AWS,
and,
we're really excited to, like,
use Rust internally a lot. And and so,
yeah, it is definitely on our road map.
It's it's a big investment to add these
languages. Go check us a year to work
on. Oh, wow. And so we really need
to be strategic about which languages we use,
we we support because it's it's quite a
lot of work. The surface if you can
imagine, the surface area of a language
is pretty large. Right? If you think about
the primitives that we need to support every
language, like classes
and interfaces and inheritance and methods and optionality
and data types. And and so to that
end and Go was actually super interested interesting
in that way because it it has its
own,
you know, idioms and and primitives and so
mapping those. Anyway,
it's definitely on the list. I don't know
if it's the second it's the next one
on the list. That's that's what I'm trying
to say. We're we're still we're still thinking
about it. Yeah. For all those good developers
that mess at our check-in every three lines,
they can now do that with their cdk8s
as well, I would imagine. So I
I read a lot of Go and I
I really enjoy Go, but I I I
really wish I had like, you know, the
question mark operator and rust where the errors
would just automatically be propagated up, but I'll
run into that another day. We don't need
to talk about that today. Okay.
So the first thing I need to do
is install the cdk8s CLI.
So I should have NPM.
I do have NPM. I'm pretty confident there.
So I'll let that run-in the background and
then we can use the cdk8s CLI
to initialize a new project.
Is there anything special about that? Or is
it just a standard,
you know, kind of node based project with
just some stuff bolted into the package you
start JSON, I would imagine. Very very strict.
It's very empty.
You'll see.
Yeah. Cdk8s is basically a library. Like, AWS
cdk8s, it's just a library and the CLI.
Right? Like, it's basically this combination.
But you can technically use cdk8s without
the CLI if you wanted. Like, it the
CLI is basically just a kind of like
a,
you know, some gives you some workflow tools
around the project. But it most of the
logic, almost all of the logic is actually
part of the library.
Okay. Well, let's just take a look at
what we got there. Now, the sidebar is
always a bit difficult to read, when I
pop stuff open, we should
have a much better view.
But it looks like a pretty
standard
node project.
I'm looking at the package dot JSON. I
can see that we're pulling in
a bunch of things. So the cdk8s plus
17 and then constructs. Maybe you just wanna
give us a little bit of
information on what each of those are.
Yeah.
So cdk8s is the main library.
It's basically where it's basically the core
the it it contains the core classes and
basically allows you to use
cdk8s,
but it doesn't have any high level abstractions.
It doesn't have any specific
support for Kubernetes resources.
In a sense, we sometimes call this l
zero, level zero, because it basically gives you
the ability to synthesize Kubernetes manifest using
a CDK paradigm.
And it has all the kind of base
classes. It has the chart class. It has,
API object class. So, basically, classes that represent
the
Kubernetes, you know,
abstract primitives, let's call it.
Now c d k cdk8s plus is what
we sometimes call l two,
which is layer two.
And we'll we'll cover it, maybe later because
I think that's worth a separate discussion, but
we we we really recommend using that. It's
actually a pretty powerful layer, and it would
be interesting for me to, like, hear what
you think about it when we get there.
And then, constructs is actually the low level
programming model that's shared across all cdks,
and that's a component model that allows you
to compose
these abstract things together into higher level concepts.
And everything in the CDK, in all CDKs,
is a construct. The app, the chart, the
API object, and everything that's higher level than
that, they're all constructs. So if you you
can think about them as as a programming
primitive in a way. They're like composable
functions.
You know? Like, they're they you can take
these two constructs and multiple constructs and create
a higher order thing from them.
And we'll see them in use, I think,
probably.
Alright. Perfect.
I have to see we have a bunch
of scripts. So I can see the import
here. I'm assuming that's for bringing in custom
resources. I'm sure we'll play with that. I'm
assuming send for just gonna is that the
generate the gamble for me?
Yep. Okay.
And then we've got some TypeScript stuff. I
I find the inclusion
of jest on a test command interesting
because I can speak from my own experience
and I can speak from, you know, you
know, when I speak to people or used
to speak to people at conferences that
testing their their codified infrastructure and application deployments
is something that people have wanted to do
for a long time and has always been
very, very painful. So I'm curious if that's
something that cdk8s is gonna make easier for
me and and what that looks like. So
that's really exciting.
Alright. What else do we have here? So
the package dot JSON is is what we've
just spent. We have our cdk8s dot yaml,
Just some boilerplate, I would imagine.
This yeah. This is basically configuration for the
CLI
so that it knows about your application. So
it knows what language you're using.
The app attribute
basically tells the CLI how to execute your
application
because it's in a sense, when you're synthesizing,
you're executing your code. Right? Like, the execution
of your program
is what produces those manifests.
And so when you're doing cdk8synth,
it needs to execute your application. And in
in in in since we support multiple programming
languages,
we need to tell the CLI how to
execute your application. So that's basically why we
have this app thing. And import is basically
a set of imports
that you can specify
via
this config file, but you can also import
via c the CLI. Right? Basically, just run
the command line to import, and we'll probably
play with that a little later.
Cool. Awesome.
Alright. Let's see.
I see that we have a main TS
and a main
JS.
So let's just pop that open.
So we're pulling constructs,
app chart and chart props. We can kinda
cover this when we get to or example,
we have a class.
Is it fair to say that this hasn't
deployed anything
or is there some magic on there?
No. Like, you can, let's try. Let's synthesize
and see what app what's what's the output.
Alright. So I could
I guess you would do m p npm
run synth?
Yeah. Or you could
do Or you could do cdk8synth,
whichever. It's the same thing.
Alright. And we get hello dot kubernetes dot
yaml in our disk directory.
Yeah. Very nice. Cool.
That's Good job. What I was expecting, I
guess. I looked at, you know, there there's
nothing Kubernetes here. That just looks like it's
setting up our app and chart. I'm not
entirely sure what those mean yet, but we'll
get to that, I'm sure.
So there's also the inclusion of a main
dot j s. Oh, this is just generated
right now. This is a compiled output. Yeah.
Exactly. Okay.
Do we ship with any test?
Yeah. Okay. Cool.
We've just got a very simple
check that thing.
Yeah. So this is in just there's a
concept called snapshot testing. I don't know if
if you're familiar with that. But, basically, it's
coming from React from the React world.
It's very good for for things like React
and things like the CDK, and there's actually
pretty interesting,
analogies between the two the two frameworks.
But the the nice thing about test snapshot
testings is that they're it I kind of
think about them as,
and I use them a lot, so I
can say that. It's like testing for lazy
people.
The it's they're very, very
crude in a way. Right? Because what what
they do is they basically
they say, okay. Let's synthesize this thing and
take a snapshot of the output
and then commit this snapshot into my source
control. And then if something changes, my test
will fail.
And so to that end, it's basically,
kind of like an end to end unit
test in a way. It basically tests the
entire thing.
And, obviously, you can, like, test smaller pieces
of it if you wanted, but, it's it's
powerful because it a it basically protects you
against unexpected
regressions.
Because one of the things that we'll see
is that as you go higher level,
you encapsulate and you abstract, and then things
can change without intention.
Right? Like, can, for example, some low level
things some some suddenly changes. You're you're, you
know, downloading a new version of some dependency,
and suddenly your your manifest changes in a
way that you didn't expect.
And so this approach of snapshot testing is
a really powerful and simple way
and cheap in many in many senses
to
to see what's happened. Right? Like, to basically
connect
the this this stack of abstractions to the
output and make sure that you know what
what's going on. And we'll we'll probably we
can play with that later if we have
some time.
Okay. Perfect.
Yeah. I'm
yeah. I'll just leave that. I haven't I
mean, I've I've babbled with TypeScript and React
and, you know, I think I've rebuilt my
blog like 14,000 times in the last one
month probably. But the testing is something I've
always avoided and I've always I always read
about jest and the way that it can
help.
Maybe my way into getting better, that will
be through cdk8s,
which would be nice.
Yeah. It's definitely it's definitely one of the
killer features of of of the CDK paradigm
is the ability to write tests and
get more confidence.
Yeah. I mean,
I I I will speak for don't wanna
put words in, you know, anyone else's mind,
but I'll speak for my own experience. And
that's that, you know, when I have what
I have what what I want as a
deployment mechanism for an application on Kubernetes is
like,
other than the image, I probably don't want
it to change that much. And the image,
don't even want to change in my manifest.
I want that to be something that happens
within the cluster. So like, I can understand
why snapshot testing
is gonna give me that really quick feedback
of, hey. This changed. And at least if
it's correct, I can still review that and
say, okay. That's that's the change that I
was expecting when I reran it. So Yeah.
And and the nice thing about
about using snapshot testing is, as I said
earlier, you can you can do snapshots on
a smaller on smaller pieces. So if you,
define if you create a construct that represents
an an abstraction, right, and you use this
construct in your app or you publish this
construct as a live user,
you can test this construct through snapshots.
And so it's not necessarily about snapshotting the
entire application. You can snapshot any scope
of that application.
And and so it's basically it is a
unit test in many you know, for all
intents and purposes, and the granularity is yours
to decide. But at the at the minimum,
I would recommend using a high level, you
know, basically, a low resolution or high level
granularity to basically make sure that you're protecting
yourself against unexpected changes or regressions.
Alright.
So if we continue then through our documentation,
we're now being introduced to kind of two
new concepts, which is the app and the
the chart.
Are these
as I would expect them to be? Are
they specific to CDK?
What is an app and chart in this
context?
So an app is basically the root so
let's let's go back to the concept of
constructs. Okay?
So though these constructs are these is composable
units of abstraction.
And the way you compose things is basically
you create a tree.
So there's a there's a root, and then
the root composes
a bunch of other things, and then that
and then these other things compose other things
together. And so in a sense, you can
think about it as a tree.
And in in the CDK, it's an also
in the c AWS CDK,
the root is called an app. Right? This
is basically the root of the construct tree
is the app. It's the everything starts from
there.
And then
the second level
is normally,
a deployment unit.
And in in cdk8s,
we use the chart we use chart this
chart name as the deployment unit, and we
borrowed it from from Helm, of course,
because they do resonate with each other. Right?
Like, it's kind of like
and and but
practically or mechanically, a chart is basically a
manifest. Basically,
synthesizes into a manifest.
The reason we didn't wanna call it a
manifest
was because
CDK terminology is about
the result. It's not about the artifact,
if that makes sense. Right? Like, for example,
I have a class called pod.
And so the class is is not called
pod manifest or pod definition. Right? It's called
pod because it represents
it models the idea of a pod in
the in the output. Right? And so to
that end, we use chart to represent a
single manifest.
And and so what you can see here
is you can see an app as a
root and then a single instance
of a a chart type.
And like oriented,
you know, programming language, there's a type and
there's an instance. And so in this case,
we're defining we're declaring a new type called
my chart, which extends
the base type of chart.
In this case, it's it doesn't do anything
with it. So it's basically the same thing.
Right? Like, it doesn't come it doesn't there
are no
no specifications
here yet,
but it is a type. So so I
can, like, instantiate it as many times as
I want, which is a very powerful idea.
And then I'm instantiating it once and adding
it to my app. And this the the
programming model the the programming
syntax is a little odd.
I'm aware of that. Like, it's definitely been
kinda like the cdk quirk, I would say.
It's basically when you're work you're you're constructing
a tree
in a way that you're doing that during
the initialization of the objects. And there's a
very power it's a very powerful idea, but
it it people sometimes it throws people
off a little bit,
because you're basically passing the parent as a
parameter to the constructor of the
of the child.
And this way and this is how you
basically bind the child to the parent.
I can talk probably
I could spend an hour just talking about
why we did it like that, but maybe
maybe we can do that later if
Yeah. I just wanna kinda It's an interesting
design decision.
Let Let me just make sure I understood
this right. So like an app then, like
for every repository I have that is doing
some sort of cdk8s deployment, I'm likely just
to have one app and it's there to
hold all of the charts that are created.
The charts themselves,
you mentioned something there that I wanna make
sure I I I definitely understood is that
a chart is one manifest. Now is that
just one YAML file that can contain multiple
Kubernetes objects, or would it correlate to one
to one with a Kubernetes object?
It's it's one YAML file. Basically, when you're
doing if you if you add another so
in your code, have one chart. Right? Let
if you let's let's play with this, and
and I'll show It's Okay. Why don't we
just yeah. That's a good idea. Why don't
we just come into this thing here Yeah.
And, like So it's Sorry. Go. Just
to to give you just to explain the
the the the
the mapping. Okay? So let's add another
on line 14. I can even I can
even do this. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We
can let's add another one here. Okay? A
low one and a low two.
Okay? K.
And
so now if you call cdk synth, let's
see what happens.
You're in the right directory?
No.
Did we say wait.
Oh,
we since since the CDK
cdk8s.YAML
if you look at cdk8s.YAML,
it actually executes the node version,
not the TypeScript version. Not here. The
the yeah. CDK. Cdk8s. Yaml. Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Alright. Okay. Yeah. The So what we
what what we need to do is we
need to actually run
compile the code. Right? Like, you we've changed
the TypeScript code, but it's actually running the
JavaScript code.
So you can either compile it explicitly, or
what I would recommend is run a watch
in the background.
So if you open another terminal window
yeah. You can do that in here and
then open another one and to use.
So that's continuously gonna compile your, your stuff.
Give it a second. I think it's probably
just Yeah. Still compiling.
Okay. Try now.
There we go. Two YAML files. We go.
So now we have two YAML files. Both
of them are gonna be empty. But then
if we we change our chart, you'll see
that these two YAML files will will have
the same output. And so let's, let's continue
like this and see how that
Okay. So why don't we add our first
resource in their chart? Like Yep. A very
standard thing on Kubernetes would just be to
add a deployment.
So I feel like, why don't we just
add a NGINX deployment and have that render
out, and then we'll see how much we
can kinda tweak and and modify that as
we need.
Okay. Sounds good.
So as we saw earlier, cdk8s.yaml
imported
the core Kubernetes API
by just saying k eight s. Mhmm.
We can do that manually if we wanted.
We can do that by changing the the
YAML file, but kinda like when we're initializing
a new app, it kinda comes in with
an imported
core Kubernetes API.
And the importer import imported,
constructs
are gonna be under the imports directory. So
if you see you see that there's an
imports directory over there? Yep.
There you go. So you see there's a
k a s dot t s file.
If you go to that Oh, go to
it. Okay. I was just gonna wait a
minute. To show you, like, going on inside.
So you see this is generated
by k by cdk8s,
and it's a it's a big file. It
contains all the core Kubernetes resources
as classes, as constructs.
Yep. And so now if you go to
the main file, we can
we can try and use the deployment one.
So let's do import. Go ahead. One of
my favorite things about using TypeScript is that
generally
thing because the the language server stuff is
also good is that you can generally work
my way through it without actually knowing what
the hell I'm doing. So I'm gonna see
if that works here. Okay. Do it. I'm
not gonna say anything.
So if I just say deployment
Hold on. Now I'm gonna start typing go
and rust and a whole bunch of other
languages like I always do. But if we
do kits
and then deployment
oh, kube deployment
and there we've got scope.
And we're gonna assume that's a string. In
fact, no, it's a construct.
Yeah. I'll come back to that. Let's just
do that for now. And then an ID
and then props, which I'm assuming Yeah. There
we go.
I'll give it a name.
Call it engine x. I've got my spec.
And I think this is one of the
you don't get this with DSLs.
Right? You don't get this
autocomplete
greatness. At least not built in.
Yeah. Exactly. Alright. Container. You should also you
should also
a little
pro tip with the Versus Code.
If you'd showed the the the completion list
list before you
just show the just, like, hover over on
one of the options.
Yeah? Mhmm.
So no. Actually, what I meant is that
if you let's
yeah.
Here. Exactly. There's a little,
scroll.
Stand on one of the put put your
mouse on one of the there's a little
icon.
Click click here.
Click here.
There you go. So now you're gonna see
if you if you if you,
hit butt
bottom and up.
If you just, like, scroll around, you'll see
all the documentation. Yeah. There you go. That's
what I'm it was very hard for me
to explain.
But, basically, you get, like, the full documentation
API documentation here.
Nice. Okay. Yeah. That's really good tip, actually.
I I had no idea about that. That's
cool. Let's see if I can use that
to work out what a construct does then.
So
there is a way to get the parameter
thing, but I can't remember. Yeah. You you
can hover over the cube. Yeah. Exactly.
Okay. So we we have this class called
construct.
I don't know if I'm supposed to do
this. No?
Alright. Okay. I'll I'll let you get me.
What what's the construct? Yeah. This is this
is in this is exactly what I said
earlier about this quirky idiom.
You always pass in this
for scope. Oh. Not scope. This. This. This
is basically how the tree is structured. Right?
You basically say, I wanna define this cube
deployment
in the scope of my chart,
right, as part of my chart. So it's
always this higher there's a there's a kind
of, like, this relation
between
your,
AST or your code, your the structure of
your code, and the structure of your construct
tree. And the way we we capture this
is by
asking you to say which scope and in
which scope you're defining every construct. So that's
the so, basically, the rule of thumb, just
always this.
Always this. Got it.
Alright. So I'm gonna just sorry. I need
to go.
Yeah. No. And then the second,
the second parameter is an ID,
and that's actually an interesting
there's an interesting point about it. Because the
name
if you look if you hover over the
metadata name field,
scroll up a little bit, you see that
it's optional.
And that's actually almost the most important the
single most important difference between
writing manifest by hand and using cdk8s.
You should not specify names
explicitly.
And the reason this is important is because
these names
are
these these automatically
generated names are the only way for cdk8s
to allow you to compose constructs together.
Right? If you give it an explicit name
and I add two instances of this construct
into the same Kubernetes
cluster, then they conflict with each other. Right?
Like, it's it's a very common problem.
And cdk8 solves this by by creating
relative naming. So the the ID that you
give a construct is relative to the scope
in which you define it. And so if
you define a subscope and you can still
call something NGINX,
but then the actual,
Kubernetes resource name would derive from the path
of that resource in in the construct tree.
So it's a very powerful
mechanism and probably one of the most important
pieces
to enable composition.
Okay. That makes make sense? It does make
a lot of sense. Yeah. Okay. So I'm
assuming I can still pass in my namespace,
though, as normal.
Yep. You can pass in namespace. You can
even specify namespace at the chart level,
and then all the resources will get the
will be in that in that namespace. You
can even I think you can even specify
namespace at the app level,
and then all the resources in the entire
app will get the same namespace.
Awesome. I like that. Okay. Now another awesome
thing about us using TypeScript and real program
languages here is that we can see this
red squiggle.
It's telling me that my manifest doesn't have
all the required fields, and it's complaining about
the selector here under the template spec. So
here.
Oh, no. It's here. Here. Yeah.
I swear I've done Kubernetes before.
And this wants a Kubernetes label slider, which
seems to be its own
type. So I'm just gonna do that and
rely on auto complete again. And then I
can do match labels.
In fact, that's probably a list, isn't it?
Of objects.
No. No. I think match label is a
is an array is a is a map.
It's just a map that I can put
anything in. So I'm assuming I can Yeah.
Just put whatever. App engine. App. Yeah.
And now what we have here is, almost
working deployment.
We'll just do engineering.
And I can also need to label the
the in the template, right, to add a
metadata
section in the templates.
Not yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Labels.
Yeah. Those those are stuff. That's always bugging
about Kubernetes, to be fair. I feel like
you should only need to define that once,
and we're forced to define the the same
redundant options twice. But Well, wait until we
get to cdk8s
plus.
But
even without cdk8s plus, we can already do
some some incredible
optima you know, some some magical thing. Let
me let me
drive for a second, if you don't mind.
Yeah. Go first.
It's called a constant.
It was invented in, like,
fifty years ago, probably.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. So yeah. We can we
can refactor
those duplications out to new variables,
drop them in. In fact,
I've
been using Pulumi to do stuff similar like
this for a long time. And there's some
weird quacks using Pulumi and it's like Terraforma
has state. I don't don't actually want that.
I just want the YAML.
But one of the things that I do
there is that because again, this is real
programming language.
Because I can just grab this.
Unless I'm assuming this is maybe what cdk8s
plus is doing.
But I could just drop this in as
a function. Right?
Mhmm. Create You could
nginx
equals
that.
Although I've lost this, so I will need
parameters. So I guess I need to pass
in scope.
Yeah. So you you can define it as
a function, or you can define it as
a as a as a construct, as a
custom construct
Yeah. Which is
again, as I said, there's a the it's
it's a it's a type of a function.
Right? It's an object oriented
function.
Alright. I just want some of the types.
I'm I'm gonna revert this. I I do
love the fact that I I have this
flexibility to kind of layer on my own
helper functions to my team. Like, if I
wanted to provide
a really simple not simple, but, you know,
a complex head and simple interface to what
we expect Kubernetes applications to look like within
our organization. Like, this just opens up so
many different new possibilities.
But let's push us back.
Okay. So we should be able to synthesize
this. Right? And we will get
there's a there's a good point. There's something
there's a disconnect in my head right now.
All we're doing is to find the two
constant values on a constructor.
Is that all we have to do? Is
that do we need to connect these up
somehow?
Two?
Well, because this constructor is creating two variables
that aren't stored on this. They're not properties
of the chart. So that's that's that's
going back to
this quirkiness that I talked about earlier. The
fact that you've created this instance and
passed in
the same scope, and as I said, this
needs to be this,
it would it would bind it to the
tree. Right? Right. And so you really don't
need you really don't need this. Right? Like,
you can really do this.
And I know it looks a little odd
to some people, but you get used to
it very quickly. It's it basically the CDK
programming model
that's based on this construct tree. So you
say new Kubernetes
deployment
inside this scope, and that's all that's all
you need.
Okay. Yep. So the fact that we are
passing through this, the the output Exactly. Instance
of this doesn't really matter because it's bound
to the tree. Yep. And it would matter
if you wanna bind it to other things.
Right? Like, you could take an output, there's
an actually API behind it, and we can
check it out later. But for this use
case, you really don't need anything.
Okay. So I'm gonna I'm assuming our watch
is still running. I'm gonna synthesize this.
And what we I guess, I'm expecting to
see is that we're gonna have two deployments
with NGINX as a base name and something
tacked on the end possibly.
Yeah. There we go.
So this is our
chart name,
the ID for the deployment,
and a random identifier,
if that's correct. It's not it's not random.
It's a hash, basically, of the path.
Right? So it basically cons it's basically rendering
the name by concatenating
the
the components of the path and and,
adding a suffix that's the the hash.
Because if it's it it needs to trim
the size. Right? Like, there's a limit in
the size. It needs to trim the size.
It needs it it uses this hash as
the unique fire.
Yeah. Of of course, it's a hash now
that I think about it because it was
like, if I run this again in my
continuous integration system, if there's no changes, I
don't want to be rolling out a Exactly.
Different name. Alright. Exactly. Now I'm gonna go
out on a limb here and just throw
something out there. But
I'm assuming that cdk8s plus doesn't really want
me to interact with cube deployments in this
kind of fashion. In fact, I'm gonna kick
a wild guess
and assume that if I want to deploy
NGINX with a service,
there's there's probably something to make that easy
in cdk8s plus. Did you wanna walk us
through Yeah.
Let's try to do that. That's a that'll
be a good way to check that out.
But I'm just gonna now instead of yeah.
Delete all this? Yeah? Or you're gonna say
something else? No. No. No. That's exactly what
I wanted you to do.
Instead of importing, k eight s, let's, let
me let me Yeah. Go for it. Drive
for a second. Okay? If you don't mind.
So
so now let's import k plus.
And
here,
I
think I I can see the
you so now you type from this point.
So now do do a new k plus.
Yep.
New k plus. K plus dot
okay. So here we have
deployment.
K.
This looks familiar. Right? Yeah. It does.
Now if you open the props, this looks
now different. Right? This this is this is
what we call an intent based API. It's
a high level higher level API
for Kubernetes deployments. It's not opinionated
about
how you use deployments. It's opinionated about the
API. Right? Like, basically leverages
the object oriented
API capabilities.
And so in this case, just do containers.
Right? And then it's an array.
And then each one basically
only requires an image because
we can probably give you a a reason
a reasonable name, and that's it.
Now let's, synthesize this.
Why? Up here.
So you see that it's it was it
actually it it actually did some cool things
for you. For example,
it created a label that matches the, you
know, this the the pod
template
with the selector of the deployment.
It also added some defaults to image pull
policy. It
gave a default for for a name, and
then all the rest is it it specified
a replica
for you, which is
one. Obviously, you can change all of those
things. But now let's let's add this,
let's add let's a service. Right?
So let's
do this like this
and see the API and explore the API
of deployment. So type deployment
and dot.
Okay. This looks interesting.
Yeah. And there's a method called
expose.
That's it. Let's just use the default and
see what happens.
And this is kind of like a design
principle we have at the higher level. You
know, the k plus is basically
minimum minimum required
fields and options and properties. Right? Like, be
very we're very eager
to to come up with correct,
safe,
sensible defaults.
Look at that.
We get a cluster IP service exposed in
port 80.
That's
I think the ergonomics here and the developer
experience is,
you know, just what people would expect. Right?
They want these tools to help them
very little friction.
I think what I also I'm gonna take
another stab in the dark here because, you
know Yeah. That was fun. Is that this
looked like it was like some sort of
builder pattern. So in theory, can I just
chain all these together?
We're actually it's not really a builder pattern
because Expose is not returning a deployment.
We deliberately try to avoid builders mostly because
they're not very familiar to every
programming language. So sometimes they feel very odd
in certain languages.
And so, like, as a design principle, we
try to avoid them.
So, yeah, you could do expose if you
don't wanna do anything else. Right? Like, it's
definitely it would definitely work,
but this is this is normally how I
would write it. Right? Yeah. So keep it's
actually returning the the service itself. Right.
Exactly. So expose returns the service, and then
you can do something with the service. Right?
You can
explore
the API of the service if you want.
Cool.
So
and just let you I mean, besides the
boilerplate,
we're, what, four four lines of TypeScript there
and we're managing to generate our engine x
deployment with a service, synthesize it, and that
could quite easily be deployed to your cluster
and
jobs done. Right? We're we're moving on to
solving real world problems on our domain and
not focusing too much on this. Yeah. Right.
Yeah. Yeah. That's the idea of this higher
level API.
And, again, people can choose to use it
or not, but
we're we're working on this higher level API.
It still doesn't cover the entire surface area
of the core Kubernetes API,
but I think we have the right patterns
thought out. And so now it's basically
our job is to basically just, like, continue
to cover.
Okay.
There's
two there's one thing in my head right
now that I'm a little confused about. So
hopefully, we can kind of expand on that.
So
when we use k
plus,
we're importing
the library.
However, for the Kubernetes objects, they're actually generated
at an imports folder. Why why are the
why is the core Kubernetes API not delivered
as a package as well?
Mostly because we don't need to deliver it
as a package. Right? And because we wanna
give you full flexibility
into,
deciding which language to you sorry, which version
to use.
And k plus is handwritten. Right? Like, this
we have we we are handwriting
these these these classes,
and we're thinking
really hard about the, you know, the the
heavy lifting that we can do at that
layer. And so in that sense, we can't
generate that.
And that's why cdk8s plus says cdk8s plus
17 because it basically it's compatible with 17
plus, right, for
version 1.17
and above.
And that but we will need to write
one for eighteen and nineteen and twenty. And
and, obviously, because we're using standard programming languages,
we can reuse a lot of stuff that
we did in '17 for stable resources and
add the new.
It's not that we really need to rewrite
the whole thing for every language version of
the of of the Kubernetes API,
but it's it's it's a it's a hand
you know, it's a it's a manual process
as opposed to the imports,
which is completely automatic, and every new version
of Kubernetes would automatically be supported. You don't
need to you don't need to do anything.
And maybe that's a good leeway to, like,
maybe looking at the CRD support. That could
be fun, fun thing to I was just
thinking that myself. I was like, why don't
we grab a custom resource and see how
we can bring that into this kind of
of workflow?
Cool.
Alright. So Do you have any particular one
that you're interested in? Well, I I do
a lot of work on the cluster API
project. So why don't we import their types?
Okay.
So they should have a release artifact here
with the YAML components.
So did I just download this YAML to
be able to import it? Can I throw
a URL at it? What what You could
throw a URL. K.
So what do we want? We want the
core component. Just a second. My battery's almost
stopped.
Oh. Please.
Is that better?
Yep. Sorry.
Does this stop yelling at you now?
Okay. So let's see. CDK import.
Nice.
The support stocks dot c r d dot
dev.
Yeah.
That's a that's a contribution from Crossplane,
which is awesome.
Yeah.
Dan from Upbound slash Crossplane is I know
he's been very
publicly working on the docs there, do that
dev stuff. So a great job that he's
doing there, definitely.
So
types to import and then
And then URL. Yeah.
Alright. Nice.
It's imported our add ons, CRDs,
and our clusters and our machine.
Yeah. And if you look at the imports
directory, you'll see
the results,
basically.
Yeah.
Awesome.
So now let's do you wanna try and
use one of those resources?
No? No. Okay. Okay.
So oh,
from
import.
Let's try and do
the cluster thing,
cluster.
Okay, so we have access to the cluster
API cluster resource,
so I should be able to do
new cluster
scope, of course,
my cluster,
the spec.
I wish I had picked that easier example
now because composing a cluster. That's
a pretty ambitious
Yeah.
It doesn't really matter. But I think you
I think you I think you can
I think you see what Yeah? What what
I wanted to see how
easy that was. And I think the answer
was stupidly easy. Like, literally
just cdk8s import,
point it to you, you know, a GitHub
URL with YAML,
and now I can begin to compose
these types. Like, that is
that's really cool. And, of course, I I
I
could spend the next twenty minutes adding infrastructure,
machine pools, machine deployments,
and Yeah. But I I don't think that's
particularly
useful to the audience. But that is really,
really simple.
I didn't actually expect that to take us
thirty seconds.
Glad to hear.
Okay. So
that, I'm assuming, just works for all custom
resources.
I'm assuming they have to have
no. Because we didn't even look at the
open API spec. So
oh, that's all embedded. The CRD includes it.
Yeah. Okay.
If the CRD doesn't include the schema for
the API, it'll basically be kind of like
an any you know, like a an open
map,
which is nice, but it's definitely
not as nice as having full, you know
Okay. Yeah. So completion.
As they don't provide the open API schema,
you can still work with it with it,
but it's just not gonna be as kind
of Tight. Fluid as yeah. Tight as you
would expect it. Like, you know,
there'll be dragons. You have to worry about
your own
fields as possible. Okay. Exactly.
Okay.
That was
very easy.
Is there anything else on cdk8s that you
wanna take a look at before we kinda
wrap up for today? Is there anything we've
missed that you think is particularly cool to
show off?
Maybe let me go let's let's go back
to the code just for a minute. I'll
I'll show you how to create a custom
construct because I feel like, that's a very
powerful tool that,
would be nice to, like, show
if you if you don't mind. No, please,
Naomi.
Okay. So I'm gonna delete this for a
second. And let's say, as you like you
said yeah. Like you did ex earlier, let's
say I wanna take these two,
you know, maybe add some more, but let's
just take these two and extract them into
a custom construct.
Okay?
So we'll call that construct
engine
x.
So, basically, defining custom construct is basically the
creating a class that extends construct.
And
from an API perspective,
it
should be compatible.
Right? So it's basically the way
NGINX props this is kinda like the standard
way of sorry.
And
we can define NGINX props here and get
empty for a second.
And then all I need to do is
basically just move these here.
Right?
And let's say,
I can add a property says port. Okay?
And I'll I'll just
document that the default is 80,
and then I can do here props dot
port
or 80, which is basically
and now let's say I want two NGINX
deployments, I can just do
this NGINX
80,
and this would be like this, and then
whatever.
Just make this up making this up.
Does that make sense?
Yes. Yeah. You can synthesize this and see
see the output, but
I think it's pretty evident, right, that it
will work because I didn't do anything special
here. It's just
programming.
Right? Yeah. So all you have to do
is create a new class that extends the
construct.
You can define your own properties that you
wanna accept just by adding an interface definition.
And then you just spec out what you
want, allowing the overrides wherever possible. And then
you provide this really nice API for your
team or the organization to just say, hey,
I wanna deploy a web app or I
wanna deploy Internet or I wanna deploy Exactly.
You know, a cron job to my customer
with certain constraints, etcetera. Like, all of that
Exactly. That everything that's doing upfront can be
Yeah. And and since these are just regular
classes,
then you can publish them as open source
libraries and share them with, you know, with
your team or with a company or or
publicly or right? Like, they're just classes. There's
nothing special about them in that sense. So
I guess that's very powerful.
Yeah. I guess this is getting into the
territory now. It's like, you know, I think
what we showed off at the start was
that
we can remove the YAML template. Like, you
know, we've all been using Helm for years,
would imagine. It's painful and quirky although it
is getting the job done. But, you know,
the problem is is these charts are trying
to encapsulate so many different optional components and
configuration that just isn't really meant to be
handled through Go templates
or YAML.
So we can bring that in house and
we can say, actually what we wanna be
able to do is provide all of these
classes that everyone can use
and
they could be shared. But then the second
thing in there that you're doing is the
same as Ashley,
you know, we can provide our own, like
elastics come out and say here is a
CDK definition for elastic search that can be
tweaked with all of these parameters by defining
a proper interface and just say go nuts.
This is how we think we should deploy
elastic search, and you can override whatever bit
you want with proper programming,
not crazy go templating. And I think that
is really powerful.
Yeah. One more point to make is that
you can also you can also just use
Helm charts in cdk8s constructs.
So if you do new Helm
let me just quickly do this.
Whatever.
Elastic.
And then if you
yeah. You need to import it. Let me
just import it here. There you go. Now
if you do code completion here, you'll see
the API.
Yep. So you can basically specify the chart
and the release and the values and whatever
you want.
And so that's a really nice way to
basically reuse Helm charts,
but you can wrap them in a custom
construct. So you can define an Elastic construct
that leverages the Helm
chart for Elasticsearch,
for example,
but offers a high level intent based API
and l two, right,
API.
So it's not necessarily that you need to
rewrite everything that you've done in Helm, for
example, if you wanna create these
ergonomics,
cdk ergonomics for them.
Yeah. I I'm assuming with the the presence
of this
executable parameter that it's first running a Helm
template locally on my machine and then consuming
those YAML files.
Does once I do the Helm template, can
I then modify that YAML or do I
just take that as is and that's just
the way the Helm stuff works?
Not sure I've understood the question. Yeah. So,
like, if I were to say, you know,
this is the elastic search chart. Oh. What's
the return on this? Is it
So cdk8s
has this concept of overrides,
which is a general concept.
Sorry.
We call it also escape patches.
You can go you can look at this
at the at the documentation. It's actually something
that, maybe documentation can help with. And the
concepts
escape patches.
And that's a general thing we add in
every CDK, but it basically allows you to
patch
the output via code.
And so to your question earlier, you can
add the Helm chart and then patch it
to your heart's extent,
and you can encapsulate all of that within
a construct. And so from a user's perspective,
they don't know what's going on. Right? Like,
it's basically just a construct that represents a
Elasticsearch
cluster or Redis, whatever.
And but you can literally
fully control the output if you need to
using JSON patching.
Yeah. Okay. Excellent.
So if you really, really need to, there's
always that way there to make any Exactly.
You have to. You can you can eject
yourself into
into YAML land,
But it's still a but it's still code.
Right? And it's still part of your code.
So I think it's even
you still have that safety, which is really
very, very important.
Yeah. Definitely.
Awesome. Very, very cool project. I I
but it's when I play with things like
this, I just I don't know
why we would default to other ways of
doing this. Like, I I think TypeScript is
such a great language for stuff like this
because of the strongly typed stuff, the good
language server support,
and
the ease of use, especially within the node
JS ecosystem for just wrapping things and functions
that take functions all the way down and
really providing abstractions
that are tailored to each unique team and
organization.
And so very, very cool. Very happy with
that.
Mhmm. Alright. Let's jump back. Yeah. We had
we we we have an sorry. And just
anecdotally,
we we have a lot of peep like,
we hear a lot from CDK users, AWS
CDK and CDK for Kubernetes,
that they've used types for the first time
because of the CDK,
and they fell in love with it.
So it's, I'm happy to hear. But, again,
a c d all those
all those tools are available in multiple
programming languages, and and,
we're really, really trying to make sure that
the experience in every programming language is as
good as as as we can.
It's not always the as it it's not
always as good as we want it to
be still, but then there's definitely room for
improvement. But,
it is we have, you know, big enterprise
customers who are using, you know, AWS CDK
in Python or in Java, and
it's it's all working very well. So it's
not
Yeah. I guess TypeScript.
You know, not to trivialize it in any
way, but, you know, all of this code
that we see in front of us regardless
of the language. I mean, you're really
we're building up a big data structure of
different types and parameters.
And then, you know,
being able to jump between languages and then
spit that out as YAML.
Again,
just so much power. So I can really
understand why teams are using Java all the
time would want to use Java. I can
understand Python and go because these are idiomatic
languages and infrastructures code and especially in the
cloud native ecosystem.
Yep. But, yeah. I I think I'm I'm
a TypeScript converter for this stuff now based
on based on, you know, my experience with
Pulumi and CDK. It's in CDK. Like, it
just it's a really good language for for
manipulating and working with with types in this
way. Mhmm.
I shoved a little link to this little
thing called we call construct catalog,
following
up on our earlier
conversation about,
publishing,
constructs.
And so if you search for cdk8s
in the search box,
you'll see that there are a bunch of
things that people already had already published
that could be interesting to, like, check out.
And this is basically kinda little prototype for
this for this catalog. We're we're we're we're
looking into, like, productizing it, so it's a
it's a little nicer. But it's a good
it it could gives you a sense of
some
initial,
you know, sparks of, like, in this initial
sparks of an ecosystem that's starting to build
around this.
That's very cool as well.
I'm pretty sure I mean, I've I'm supposed
to be recording my cube talk cube con
talks this week, and one of them is
commoditizing cluster API as code using TypeScript.
And I've I I really just wanna kinda
rewrite all of it in cdk8s now
and publish that as a module. So I'm
trying to work out in my head if
I could do that in under two days
and still record a talk. So watch this
space. Well,
let let me know if you need some
help.
Alright. Let's jump back over to here.
Thank you so much for joining me today
and guiding us through that. It's such a
powerful tool. I hope everyone watching
kinda gets a taste of this that goes
away and checks it and checks it out.
I really do believe these tools are the
best way to deploy to Kubernetes.
Is there anything that you would like to
finish with before we wrap up for today?
Anything you wanna share? Anything you wanna link
to? Anything you want in the show notes?
I guess the only thing that I can
that that's important to say is that, cdk8s
is in beta,
so it's still not final. We still have
some work to do to get it to
a place where we're
comfortable calling it,
production.
But I I think we know that there
are you you know, we have people using
it for production purposes.
I think the the main thing that we
wanna make sure
we have right is, you know, the API
patterns that are solid that we can cover
the core Kubernetes API with these high level
abstractions,
make sure that we that supporting multiple versions
of Kubernetes
is solid. It's a very important piece in
the Kubernetes world.
But my point is that it's a great
time to get involved and influence and collaborate
with us and help us, build this.
It it was accepted to CNCF as a
sandbox project recently, so we're also very excited
about that. Oh, wow. I was I must
have completely missed that. Awesome. That's really, really
cool.
So it's the CNCF sandbox project. It works
across multiple languages and runtimes.
It's m beta. Contributions are welcome. Get involved.
Hopefully, help shape the future of Kubernetes deployment.
Let's leave it at that. Thank you,
Pleasure for you to join me today. Really
cool technology. Looking forward to playing with it.
And I will let you know how I
get on with my cluster API hack Yeah.
Over the next forty hours. Yeah.
Please. I'd be very curious.
Alright. Thank you very much. I'll speak to
you Thank you for having me. Bye.